so we are interested in studying the
relationship between the amount that
folks study for a test and their score
on a test where the score is between
zero and six and so what we're going to
do is go look at the people who took the
tests we're going to plot for each
person the amount that they studied and
their score so for example this data
point is someone who studied an hour and
they got a one on the test and then
we're going to fit a regression line and
this blue regression line is the actual
regression line for these four data
points and here is the equation for that
regression line now there's a couple of
things to keep in mind normally when
you're doing this type of analysis you
do it with far more than four data
points the reason why i kept this to
four is because we're actually going to
calculate how good a fit this regression
line is by hand and typically you would
not do it by hand we have computers for
that
now the way that we're going to measure
how good a fit this regression line is
to the data has several names
one name is the standard deviation of
the residuals another name is the root
mean square deviation sometimes
abbreviated rmsd sometimes it's called
root mean square error so what we're
going to do is is for every point we're
going to calculate the residual and then
we're going to square it and then we're
going to add up the sum of those squared
residuals
so we're going to take the sum
of the residuals
residuals
squared
and then we're going to divide that by
the number of data points we have minus
two and we can talk in future videos or
a more advanced statistics class of why
you divide by two
but it's related to the idea that what
we're calculating here is a statistic
and we're trying to estimate a true
parameter as best as possible and n
minus 2 actually does the trick for us
but to calculate the root mean squared
deviation we would then take a square
root of this
and some of you might recognize strong
parallels between this and how we
calculated sample standard deviation
early in our statistics career and i
encourage you to think about it but
let's actually calculate it by hand as i
mentioned earlier in this video to see
how things actually play out so to do
that i'm going to give ourselves a
little table here so let's say that is
our x value in that column
let's make this our y value
let's make this
y hat which is going to be equal to 2.5
x minus 2
and then let's make this the residual
squared which is going to be
our y value minus our y hat value our
actual minus our estimate for that given
x
squared and then we're going to sum them
all up divide by n minus 2 and take the
square root
so first let's do this data point so
that's the point 1 comma 1
1 comma 1. now what is the estimate from
our regression line well for that x
value when x is equal to 1 it's going to
be 2.5 times 1 minus 2. so it's going to
be 2.5 times 1 minus 2 which is equal to
0.5
and so our residual squared is going to
be 1 minus 0.5 1 minus 0.5
squared which is equal to that's going
to be 0.5 squared which is going to be
0.25
all right let's do the next data point
we have this one right over here it is 2
comma 2.
now our estimate from the regression
line when x is equal to when x equals 2
is going to be equal to 2.5
times our x value times 2
minus 2 which is going to be equal to
3.
and so our residual squared is going to
be 2
minus 3
to
minus 3 squared which is negative 1
squared which is going to be equal to 1.
then we can go to this point so that's
the point 2 comma 3 2 comma 3.
now our estimate from our regression
line is going to be 2.5
times our x value times 2
minus 2
which is going to be equal to
3.
and so our residual here is going to be
zero and you can see that that point
sits on the regression line so it's
going to be 3 minus 3 3 minus 3 squared
which is equal to 0. and then last but
not least we have this point right over
here when x is 3
our y value this person studied 3 hours
and they got a 6 on the test
so y is equal to 6 and so our estimate
from the regression line you could say
what you would have expected to get
based on that regression line is 2.5
times our x value times 3 minus 2 is
equal to
5.5
and so our residual squared is 6 minus
5.5 squared minus 5.5
squared so it's 0.5 squared which is
0.25
so now the next step let me take the sum
of all of these squared residuals
so this is let me just write it this way
actually let me just do it like this
so the sum
of the residuals
residuals squared is equal to
if i just sum all of this up it's going
to be point it's going to be 1.5
1.5 and then if i divide that by n minus
2 so if i divide by n minus 2 that's
going to be equal to i have four data
points so i'm going to divide by 4 minus
2 so i'm going to divide by 2
and then i'm going to want to take the
square root of that then we want to take
the square root of that and so this is
going to get us 1.5 over 2 is the same
thing as 3 4. so it's the square root of
three-fourths or the square root of
three
over two and you could use a calculator
to figure what that is to figure out
what that is as a decimal but this gives
us a sense of how good a fit this
regression line is the closer this is to
zero the better the fit of the
regression line the further away from
zero the worse fit and what would be the
units for the root mean square deviation
well it would be in terms of whatever
your units are for your y-axis in this
case it would be the score on the test
and that's one of the other values of
this calculation of taking the square
root of the sum of the squares of the
residuals dividing by n minus 2. so big
picture this square root of 3 over 2 can
be viewed as the approximate size of a
typical or average prediction error
between these points and what the
regression line would have predicted or
you could view it as the approximate
size of a typical or average residual